do you remember that quaint era in
american politics in 2008 where we
thought sarah palin is the craziest that
anyone involved in politics will be
sarah palin is the wackiest sarah palin
is the most cartoonish and ignorant and
unqualified we're never gonna see
anything uh uh below sarah palin and of
course we were very wrong and then came
trump and trumpism and a bevy of
candidates uh worse than sarah palin but
sarah palin has gotten even worse over
the last couple of decades sarah palin
is now running for member of congress in
alaska she was invited to speak both
before trump at the trump rally in
anchorage and during
and it was really really weird sarah
palin called
on alaskan chicks
to show people
what makes them women
now
if you've uh
looked at
you know maybe certain medical journals
lately uh if
the question of
showing what makes you a woman
is an interesting thing to demand women
do
but that's what sarah palin did check it
out to our leaders not being able to
tell us
they don't know what a woman is
hey all you alaskan chicks out there
maybe you can show them tell them what a
real
show everybody how you know that you're
a woman a very very strange request then
sarah palin was invited up during
trump's speech to speak
almost completely incoherent now we've
talked before
sometimes sarah palin really struggles
to use words and then to combine them
and to try to communicate things of
meaning
this is maybe the worst i've ever seen
her a lot of people asked me how did you
know that you'd know that president
trump that donald j trump was going to
be the best president that we'd ever had
how did how did you think to uh to get
out there and endorse them early when
gosh you know there was a lot of uh
party pressure on me and others to
endorse you know established candidates
and all that and um i knew well
personally speaking for years
even trump is confused by this and he'll
accept any praise but this he's like
what is she talking about donald trump
watched what the fake media the fake
news the lame stream media put my kids
through okay
remember this
the things that you guys did to my kids
by the way the pointing to the back
nobody's covering these rallies it's
basically newsmax right side
broadcasting
and if i don't have anything better
going on i'll cover their coverage
there's not whatever they think of as
the fake news media there's none of it
there nobody's even talking about these
things don't trump he would write me a
note and he would say hang in there
the people who know you they love you
they know the truth about your family
sitting right over there god bless you
hi trig
and i knew that this man cared about
family yeah trump really a deeply
spiritual and also really a family man
um at another point sarah palin
suggested that the right not retreat but
rather reload which is really a great
message when we're plagued by mass
shootings
my dad
no he was all about no you stiffen your
spine you use what they throw at you as
fuel
let it strengthen and fortify you
and you fight for what is right well my
dad's words exactly were
don't retreat reload
now that's a message the crowd can get
behind thinly veiled allusions to
violence at a time during we are with
which we are plagued by mass shootings a
couple uh other real quick ones in this
segment sarah palin discusses donald
trump's balls
out of all of them because i knew them
all
he was the only one who had the balls to
take on the fake media thank you
and to take on hillary clinton
yeah clinton
um and lastly sarah palin during her
speech
using the term plandemic which of course
is
a buzz word for the utter
bottom feeding worst of the worst
coveted conspiracy theorists
this is life changing what's coming up
here in the midterms the changes that
are needed and it's no longer democrat
versus republican
this is all about control versus freedom
it's
it's good versus evil
it is a spiritual battle
[Applause]
they use the plandemic as an example in
order to achieve a goal of controlling
you the plan endemic so this now is
welcomed
by
what has become the mainstream of the
republican party
trumpism and later in the show or maybe
tomorrow if i don't get to it we are
going to take a deep look at polling
data
is trumpism currently dominant in the
republican party it's an important
question in thinking about these
midterms and about 2024. we're going to
take a quick break all of these clips if
you were just listening today and you
have a sort of morbid sick curiosity as
to what it looked like we will have
these clips on our instagram at david
pakman show and then after the break
we'll look at a couple of interviews
with rally goers and i will warn you
it's just as bad or worse uh than sarah
palin
our sponsor javi makes coffee from
concentrate this is so fast and easy and
convenient and i'm looking for fast easy
and convenient right now but i don't
want to sacrifice on flavor the taste is
great it's cost effective you can use it
for hot or cold coffee it comes in
original decaf caramel or caramel please
pick whichever pronunciation you want
french vanilla and mocha it does not
have sugar it does not have dairy you
can add whatever liquid you want water
milk oat milk etc the ingredients are
delicious coffee concentrate and for the
flavored ones natural flavors the coffee
is ethically sourced click the link in
the description
use code pacman for 25 percent off